graficar la desigualdad de menos 4 x
menor que menos tres menos tres así que
la primera cosa que debemos hacer es
poner esta desigualdad en la forma mx
más b es decir por ejemplo empezamos con
yemen los 4x menor que menos 3 de aquí
sumamos 4x de ambos lados
ok sumamos 4x de ambos lados y lo que
nos queda es del lado izquierdo es que
estos dos se cancelan y nos queda ya
menor que 4x menos 3 ok
vamos a si vamos a dejarlo así 4x menos
3 que es la forma digamos más familiar
que tenemos 4 x 3
y ahora podemos intentar graficar esto
pero primero quiero que chequeamos algo
muy cuidadosamente voy a dibujar mis
ejes este es el eje x el eje horizontal
y este es el eje vertical el eje y
aunque ya aquí está y queremos ser
cuidadosos porque este es el 4x menos 3
no va a estar incluido en la solución no
sea igual a 4 x menos 3 no está incluido
pero bueno esto lo que nos va a dar es
digamos la solución de estos son esto
del área debajo de la línea igual a 4 x
menos 3 así que vamos a intentar dibujar
la línea frontera así que la línea
frontera más o menos parecería algo así
la frontera la frontera sería igual a 4
x menos 3 y no tenemos que esto no es
parte de la solución porque este es un
menor estricto pero nos va a ayudar a
dibujar esencialmente toda la solución
como su frontera
tenemos aquí la pendiente y aquí la
intersección con el eje leo así que
también podríamos tomar dos puntos y eso
nos ayudaría a definir una sola línea
entonces digamos por ejemplo tomemos un
par de valores de x digamos cuando x
vale 0 esto es 4 x 0 - 3 que es menos 3
ok que de hecho es nuestro punto de
intersección con el eje y verdad
entonces tenemos aquí nuestro punto cero
menos 3 y digamos ahora que cuando x es
igual a no sé digamos vamos a ponerle a
2 entonces tenemos 2 bueno 4 por 2 es 8
menos 35 entonces cuando nos vamos a x
igualados y subimos 1 2 3 4 5 y tenemos
este punto y ahora simplemente unimos
estos dos puntos con una línea o también
podríamos este decir bueno por cada uno
que nos movemos en x avanzamos 4 verdad
eso es lo que nos está diciendo la
pendiente
aquí ya podremos dibujar claramente la
línea y lo hacemos de forma punteada
porque recordemos que está esta línea no
es parte de la solución
me movía un poco
entonces tenemos estos tres puntos que
pasan por el por la línea que lo voy a
dibujar con una línea punteada
y se va a ver algo más o menos de esta
forma que por cierto otra vez no es
parte de la solución la solución son
todos los 10 menores que está recta así
que si ponemos un x aquí ok entonces de
la que está o del punto que está en la
línea nos vamos a tomar todas las 10
menores a esas así que en realidad
estamos tomando toda esta área ok
no estamos incluyendo la línea y por eso
le estamos poniendo de forma punteada
también puedes intentar algunos valores
de fuera no digamos este a esto nos
divide en dos regiones por ejemplo
podríamos probar esto tomando menos un
punto fuera de la región como el 0 0
por ejemplo este punto el origen el 0 0
tenemos que sigue de 0 y x0 tenemos 0 -
finalmente 0 es menor que menos 3 que
claramente no es el caso verdad esto no
es cierto no es cierto y tiene sentido
verdad porque el 0,0 se sale del área
que define nuestra solución ahora
digamos vámonos del otro lado al algo
digamos este punto el 30 que este es el
2.0
entonces el 30 será éste
este debería funcionar porque está
dentro de la región verdad pero vamos a
verificarlo entonces si es 0 en este
caso es 0 y es menor que 4 por equis que
en este caso es 3 menos 3 y tenemos 0
menor que 12 menos 30 menor que 9 lo
cual es cierto siempre así que estos
satisface la desigualdad en general
esto es esto nos dibuja la línea de
frontera le dibujamos de forma punteada
porque no estamos incluyendo lo en la
solución porque es un menor estricto así
que la desigualdad va a ser toda la
región debajo de esta línea de la 4x
menos 3